so that's why yeah Roger Smith's life is
over well I say as long as if I am ego
killer behind I ruin his life and look
into his [ __ ] kids Barrett Brown
spent more than four years in prison in
no small part because of this YouTube
video in which he appears to threaten an
FBI agent but how did it even get to
this point remember the hacker group
Anonymous
the guys who work Guy Fawkes masks and
release ominous videos threatened to
take down government agencies
corporations and religions like
Scientology we are anonymous we are
legion we do not forgive
well Brown rose to semi Fame when the
media characterized him not entirely to
his liking as the spokesman for
anonymous it would be his association
with hackers that would later land him
in federal prison but Barrett Brown is
actually not a hacker he's more of a
hybrid activist and investigative
journalist he first ran into trouble
after he launched a crowdsource research
platform
devoted to investigating the private
intelligence sector think a privatized
version of the NSA that counters
perceived enemies of large corporations
and government after a major email hack
Braun and his team uncovered and
publicized a conspiracy among several of
these private intelligence firms to
among other things attack and discredit
journalists what exactly landed Brown in
prison is a bit complicated and get to
it later but what's important to know
for now is that Brown just got out in
November and is already working as a
journalist covering the City Council for
D magazine in Dallas Texas but as is
always the case with Barrett Brown there
might be more here than meets the eye
he says he's already working on a
project that disrupt things in Dallas
and way beyond we met up with Barrett at
the D magazine headquarters to talk
about this time in prison the state of
the private intelligence sector and to
get his read on America's current
political situation and the role hackers
and leakers have played era thanks very
much for talking to us
thank you could you just give us an
overview of what your impression of
federal prison was it was very
educational to be within the confines of
the government to actually be there 24
hours a day watching government
officials walk around
conducted so it gave me additional
perspective on how these people think
how institution operates in contrast how
it's supposed to operate
what were your some of your observations
about the prison guards and other
federal employees they'll do whatever's
convenient in any given time I was
number up spent about six months
altogether in the Shu and the special
housing unit the whole is more popularly
known a couple of occasions entirely
without justification it was known that
I was in there without justification I
was being calculated against by a
particular administration official the
assistant warden in this case and these
these fellows staff there who generally
approved of my work they all they all
read my columns they can do actually
have you Michael like her right
libertarian views system extent
nonetheless will happily confine a
journalist in the hole they will do
whatever is asked of them and that's
that's important to know it's important
to keep in mind that you know we need to
know about the apparatus we have the
personal apparatus we have in this
country we didn't know what cops will do
what ex-military people will do what
bureaucrats will do even when they don't
agree with it when we're going into a
period of potential disarray Civic
disarray as we are now we need to be
thinking about those back a lot of civil
libertarians and other critics of our
prison system believe that the Shu
solitary confinement is inhumane cruel
punishment do you think that that's a
fair characterization based on your
experience solitary confinement has been
shown by countless studies you know to
have a certain effect on people's
mentality on their emotional life I was
very rarely in solitary confinement as
such as it's more common to have a shoe
setup where you have two people living
in a Cell they do that for a number of
reasons one of which is space one of
which is to make suicides more difficult
and people can you used to anything
that's not see that's the interesting
thing about being a human being is that
you know and we know this from history
is that people have to get used to
sometimes anything so I can't say I
suffered a great deal I tried to take
advantage of the situation much as
possible I got to my best work done in
the shoe
but no that's that's not possible for a
lot of people not everybody has
something they can make it attend to
while they're held back there and
oftentimes they're held back they're far
longer than supposed to even according
to DLP zone policy I've seen it happen
many many times that's one of several
overlapping issues in the US prison
system that need to be addressed the
fact that Obama had to come out and
forbid children from being held in the
shield or in solitary is telling about
our society that that's not something
that should have had to be done just now
and that's something that should've been
addressed a long time ago and you
mentioned that you were put in there
often without explanation at some point
your email access was suspended you
believe for communicating with the
journalists about corruption in the
Bureau of Prisons you discovered through
some FOIA request that you were
classified as an inmate of greatest
concern what does that mean and why do
you think you were one I was listed as a
hacker which not even the DOJ claims I'm
a hacker
I think the reasoning on that is it
would be kind of embarrassing to say
this guy's a journalist she's writing
about us just be wary of them he can't
really make that explicit a situation
like that and of course the reason I was
actually aware of that classification
was I was told by a staff member
contrary to policy because I am a
journalist if one of my tactics as
opposed to hacking is actually to
develop sources among people who are
unhappy with the institutions they work
for and that happened time and again
within the prison system that needs to
be kept in mind both from people who
actually suppose these institutions need
to be kept in mind by those of us who
tend to oppose these institutions that
there are fractures there that could be
taken advantage of they're not thinking
as a board there's individuals here who
disagree with a great deal of what they
do and what their government does but
doesn't let us continue to work for the
government
those people generally aren't going to
be very useful they tend not to have a
strong moral Center almost by definition
so but these are all things that are
going to come into play more and more as
our civil society continues to fracture
Barrett Brown's arrest like many of the
more dramatic moments in this
I would caught on camera because it
happened in the middle of a video chat
you could you just described what
actually happened that night doing a
project p.m. video chat as I did most
evenings at that point I heard a
rustling at the door opened it and I see
some very confusing scene of a guy with
a big metal shield the faceplate and
there's yelling and they came in knocked
me over my arm was under my chest this
SWAT team fellow dug his knee into my
back you can hear me screaming on the
video my lids been pressed into my
organs and you can hear the audio speech
you know explaining that to him and that
I can't
as he's requesting move my arm put it
behind my back because he's pressing
down on my spine
they took because Federal Building I had
some injuries to my ribs that last for a
few months I had a bottom bunk pass
because of that I wasn't able to climb
into a top bunk for a while and you know
that's about I think probably Holloway
generally happens I'm trying to imagine
what the justification for a SWAT raid
like that would be where they hoping to
catch you in the act of hacking into
intelligence firm or something it would
be for fun I mean they have all this
equipment it cost a lot of money you
know they don't get to necessarily use
as much as they press would like to and
so when they get a chance to do what
they do with gusto Brown was somewhat
famously charged for among other things
sharing a link in a chatroom
to classify data that had been obtained
in a hack of a private security firm
called rat
curiously stratford wasn't mentioned in
the original search warrants bail Brown
believes that this was because they were
actually interested in a different line
of work he had launched crowdsource
platform called Project p.m. to
investigate the murky world of private
intelligence contract
caps of the hack of a firm called HBGary
Brown and his team discovered in hacked
emails but several of the firms joined
together into a conglomerate called team
diamond one of team C misses projects
was to develop potential lines of attack
against critical organizations like
wiki's and journalists like Glenn
Greenwald and they detailed some of
their methods in a PowerPoint
presentation that Brown and team
distributed to the media Brown believes
the team Themis investigation is what
put him on the best radar we know what
this case is about this case is about HP
Gary is about endgame systems it was
about this large informal network of
state and corporate contractors and
intelligence officials who believe that
we have too much freedom to speak out
against US policy what is the public
interest in knowing this information we
found executives and we found developers
with these companies and we found
government officials colluding against
the US public in ways that have no no
defense these technologies are still a
little understood in many cases two
entirely unknown outside of a few
companies and which have the ability to
influence our national consciousness in
ways that would've been impossible to
compete generations ago explain that a
little bit what are some of the methods
that we do understand now that they use
to influence the public consciousness or
public opinion the most disturbing is
persona management this is something
that came out of the HP Gary emails
about a month after the original hacks
is one of our main focuses there was a
contract put out by CENTCOM under the US
Air Force for companies to develop
software methodologies by which a single
person sitting at a desk could control
say 10 to 20 fake online people with
with names backgrounds histories that
the software facilitates their
conversations from day to day as and
they're able to maintain a certain not
just speaking a different language you
know through translation software but
even maintain particular cadence
remember what was said and that can be
used in a number of different ways I
mean if you've seen you know what could
happen with a single person just in a
very primitive way creating sock puppets
online
in order to you know fake incidents you
know an incidents are what drives our
media coverage given the systemic
problems with our media when you start
bringing in these alliances of companies
that can now alter the public
perceptions in ways they're still in
understood we're looking towards a
period of extraordinary confusion even
beyond what we've had enough for today
one of the fbi's moved during the
investigation with charge Brown's mother
with obstruction of justice for moving a
laptop out of their view he says this is
what ultimately sent him over the edge
and led him to create this bizarre
three-part video series in which he
appears to threaten the lead
investigator on case the threats against
an officer charge scut during the plea
bargain anchoring which Browns legal
team negotiated down from a maximum
sentence of more than a hundred years to
63 months what was your mindset at that
point when that video when I was on I
had gotten off heroin a while back I was
using suboxone synthetic opiate to
control my heroin addiction and I was
trying to get off the boxer at that
point I also stopped taking a depressant
called paxil that I've been on for the
past few months and apparently when you
do that it kind of leads to a manic
state but the more important background
on that was that you know for the past
several months I've been actively
investigated by the FBI they raided my
apartment they raided my mom's house
they've taken a number of computers they
issued threats to indict my mother I
felt that at this point I was I was
going to wonder and my mother might you
know go under as well so I given up you
know conventional methods of bringing
this to attention I decided to make a
video explaining all everything that had
happened would have been done by by
certain people associated HBGary who had
posted by my actual address it was hard
to find at that point my mother's actual
address for the Zetas during a point
when the data's were supposedly going to
come kill me because of this anonymous
operation the Zetas drug cardiologists
to be clear yes those would have been
regarded as illegal had we done them
against somebody but the Faculty's
ex-military people were doing them and
the fact that that is all kind of on
Twitter online I guess perhaps struck
many journalists as they morph this
internet drama as opposed to a real
thing that actually matters
so I given up asking for help I figured
that my only option here is lay
everything out explain what's happened
make an ultimatum
explain that if they come back again
in conjunction with what I consider to
be a criminal conspiracy against me very
similar because criminal conspiracies
we'd already exposed that I would defend
my household against sending up the
items in addition to that separate from
that I also said that I was going to
ruin this
federal agents life I was going to do
exactly what aaron barr had been shown
to be planning against the families of
activists as part of his team famous
operation it wasn't a violent threat it
was a threat to use these same methods
but ultimately because the way the
indictment was phrased the way they cut
out part of that sentence in the way
they conflated two different sentences
from different ports of the video that
was really the close the prescott was
was more ambiguous than the actual when
i delivered which could be seen on the
video and so there was this conception
that i'd actually threatened to kill
this agent so these were all flimsy
charges nonetheless i did eventually
plead to it because the alternative was
to go to trial with FBI agents who had
already lied about me several times on
the stand in different hearings and
that's generally you know you want to
avoid that generally there's been
critiques of anonymous and wiki leaks
from all angles but the one I'm most
interested in hearing your response to
comes from people like Glenn Greenwald
and Edward Snowden who say that the
uncured release of information releasing
you know innocent people's credit card
information and so on is actually
damaging to the project of transparency
what's your response to that on the
whole there's a number of reasons not to
release huge large caches of information
one of which is that when you do it's
not very effective you tend to work
better if you release parts of it that
you've analyzed or you release parts of
it's a different drum we'll see work
with and that's actually what WikiLeaks
and sometimes Anonymous for the most
part is done
I was always opposed the kind of stuff
that louis ii did when they kind of went
off the reservation right and summer
2011 just started hacking things for fun
and that's really what it was there were
times when they would say oh we're doing
this to remind you about security what
that's [ __ ] they weren't doing that
i knew these guys they were doing it for
fun and to some extent principles being
done in part under hector mark to your
Saba who at that point with the FBI
asset there's reason to believe that
that kind of behavior was encouraged by
the FBI but those FBI wouldn't better
step in and get them to do that that's
the kind of stuff
a segment of anonymous had already done
when you have a activist movement that's
really built on what was previously a
trolling group those are inevitable
problems and that was one of many
reasons why different times I detached
myself from what was going on anonymous
concentrated more on a group that I
could you know control to some extent or
at least know what it was doing at least
you know something I could say this is
something that I approve of since the
four years have passed with you behind
bars I would say the world has gotten
even leakier we've seen the impact that
WikiLeaks has had on this past election
what's your reading on the election and
the role that leaks played in it I mean
now we're seeing the age of non-state
actors sort of come and come into its
own we're seeing this bizarre scenario
in which individuals can you know how
the lever by which they can move large
objects in ways that again this all
comes from from the Information Age and
the fact that for the first time in
human history and the individual can
collaborate with any other individual on
the planet and the implications of that
are not yet fully realized but I think
with this past election we're seeing
what that means
it's obviously a chaotic situation it's
an unpredictable situation you can say
that there's going to be more leaking
there's going to be continual leaking
leaking we'll have a it will play a role
and as that becomes more obvious you'll
have more institutional actors taking
that into account whether it be these
new methods some of which came out of
the HBGary emails about which companies
are going to try to prevent leaking
before it happens using predictive
technology there will also be a number
of civic insurgent groups as you might
call them that will that will take
advantage of these factors as well just
like they have with Anonymous and
WikiLeaks other groups you're going to
see more of the same in that regard in
addition to his work covering local
politics at D Magazine Brown is working
on a book and collaborating with other
activists to create something called the
pursuance
at decentralized activism network
applying lessons he learned from
anonymous and project PM to affect media
and public policy going to sort of
provide some rigor to this new dynamic
whereby anybody can collaborate with
anybody else you've imagined a empty
space and a user creates in a empty
space a square that square is the sort
of Constitution slash DNA of this group
he's creating color pursuance that group
at that point could be anything it could
be a prison reform network it could be
something for your local city to
organize opposition to a certain policy
or many policies so you have a square
here this is the DNA here's a circle
observing the person who created it you
can have spokes running off himself
they'll say one of these is one of this
is press relations one of these is
research rather than feeling that you
were a citizen of this particular
country for whatever reason and then
having to contend with your neighbors
who may or not be fascists this is
something where everybody's on the same
page where everybody at every step of
the way has the right to be there has
the right to leave and ultimately can
expect to see their ultimate political
goals accomplished in ways that we've
already seen on a small scale to
nonnamous that we've seen with other
groups of that nature this is something
that systematize instead this is
something that takes this this huge
river of information and channels it in
ways that make sense
but the point is you need to be thinking
about how we reform the wider society
rather ambitiously if necessary look at
what we have assess the environment and
start building something else there at
Brown I look forward to reading the book
and seeing this project come to fruition
and I want to thank you for talking to
us to that look for reason and Zac way
smaller
[Music]
[Music]
all
Oh
[Music]